so today we have Lauren McCarthy she is
an artist based in LA could you give us
a quick background sure um I'm an artist
based in LA I'm a assistant professor
here at UCLA design media arts but my
art is basically thinking about what are
the systems we use to be a person and
interact with other people and will
technology save all of our problems or
cause many more you have an answer yes
so at like at the footer of your website
on your about page you wrote I make art
about what confuses me is that still
true is your website old oh yeah I know
it's definitely true um the main thing
that confuses me is just people all of
them so I make art about people and
about you know the sort of expectations
we have of each other or the rituals and
the patterns and the the strange things
we do when we're together or alone hmm
and so I guess to give people some
context can you just like reference one
of your projects that that is about
people sure yeah um so maybe to give it
an example I did a project called social
triggers a few years ago and I was
trying to see if I could fix my my
non-existent dating life so I made this
system where I went on a series of blind
dates with people that I met on the
Internet and then I discreetly streamed
the video of the date to the web and
then I paid people through the service
called Amazon Mechanical Turk small
amounts of money to watch the date and
try and give me instructions for what to
say or do to see if that they might be
better at kind of coaching me or
directing me through this this date and
that was that successful for you um yeah
to some extent maybe less successful
that I had hoped but also less
successful than I had feared yeah the
thing that it did really was make
I guess one thing I'm always trying to
do without getting too philosophical
here's understand like what are these
limits we put on ourselves and so for me
to get these instructions oh yeah so
they would come as like text messages
and I have to do them or say them
immediately and so just having to do
these things and not being totally in
control felt really uncomfortable at
first but then also like started to
become really natural but the thing it
made me realize just like I could say or
do things that I felt like oh that's not
me or that that's totally weird of me to
do and then like the date would not you
know act like it was such a strange
thing to say or do and so it like the
sky didn't fall and so I realized what a
narrow box I normally hold my idea of
myself in and so what that project was
really successful in doing was just
getting me to like kind of loosen up my
identity I guess in some way yeah they
had no idea that this was going on while
you were doing it they didn't and that
was part you know I didn't I started out
with these where I would tell them at
the beginning of the date because I you
know it wasn't supposed to be at this
secret thing but the problem was that
the whole date would be just talking
about the project and about the issues
around it and surveillance and art and
which was great but it didn't feel like
a first date then it was just them
quizzing me about my art practice and so
I switched to like telling them at the
end or after the facts just to try and
get a more get this feeling that like
this is this thing we all do we don't
talk about it yeah we're doing it so was
it um just really eye-opening for you to
give up control and let other people
like basically do the date for you in a
way that like made you more comfortable
with other people over time or was it
just that individual experience that was
just different yeah I know I think it
did have some lasting effect where I
sort of thought with a loose nastain
from that project it like almost by
giving up control I started to feel more
freedom in some way but the other weird
effect was that like immediately after
the project I had gotten really used to
the system that like for the first few
days I felt really like unsure about how
to make a decision like you know like
can I kiss you or like if you want to
come home like do you want to have a
second date I was like I don't know how
to determine those things anymore
oh my god it's like have you wanted to
jump on the other side and let control
other people yeah I don't know unless so
I have less of maybe my controlling of
other people as just by setting up these
situations and asking if they'll
participate
I was wondering with like all these
projects if you if you're just
attracting more people like you to run
the date for you it has the problem I
get at least socially enough people as
my as my turkeys huh maybe I don't know
it is interesting that with a lot of
these projects were those different
roles I talked to someone and they
immediately are like oh I want to be
this on the side of it or I want to be
on the other side of it or I want to do
neither of those things and for every
person it's like really clear in their
head but different so crazy and it was
there a moment like before all this like
the art projects got started the
programming got started that you you
recognize that you're having difficulty
interacting with people oh yeah
definitely incident like throughout your
did you study art in college yeah I
studied computer science and art and I
maybe the maybe this is the source of
all my problems but I went to MIT where
it like I feel like the one thing I
didn't learn was any social skills and
so I never felt that like inadequate in
college it was like immediately
afterwards I was like oh wow all these
people know how to like interact with
each other weird when was I supposed to
get that one so I was like well what can
I do I can like kind of hack things I
guess I can build software maybe that
would help but it seems like you're
you're in this interesting place in
between right because you also had that
your JavaScript thing which was p5.js
which is like about opening up art and
technology as a whole right so obviously
like larger issues you're trying to
tackle as well or is that just because
you found that like you
to MIT so you were given the aptitude to
get into programming and like make art
and you felt that people couldn't do it
um yeah no I think it's so I have this
feeling where I don't I think part of my
social anxiety or awkwardness comes from
just a feeling of like I just don't know
how to fit in to a lot of situations and
so another place where there's a big
problem with people fitting in or
feeling welcome is in tech in general
and I think that was what really got me
interested in like working as p5.js
project it was and not just tech like
open source is even worse like in terms
of like the gender breakdown or
minorities that are involved and so I
was just trying to see like what would
it look like if the number one goal of
this project was to build a space where
people feel welcome and use that as a
starting point not like oh we built this
cool tool and then oh crap like can we
get some more you know different people
in here after the fact and yeah so
that's you know I like JavaScript I like
building this tool but that is the the
core from me is like can we make a space
work like people just feel comfortable
being there even if they don't know yet
how to code or they don't know how they
fit in or they don't know the other
people it's not working like what about
this product of this particular like I
mean it's an entire like framework right
for building yeah what about it is
attractive most people I think it's part
of it is the design so if we have that
core value of like we want to support
you know diversity in different points
of view from the get-go part of that
goes into design decisions about the
tool itself like trying to make the like
the language itself understandable the
functions in the library trying like
putting a really heavy emphasis on
documentation so it's not this barrier
where you have to figure it out it's
like someone has actually helped want
you to learn and an else is actually
doing things behind the scenes of taking
some trade-off
the code like under the hood to make it
easier for people that are not like
expert developers to still be
contributors to that codebase so adding
a lot more commenting in there and just
doing things in slightly less sort of
obscure ways that's really cool I never
thought about that like just opening up
like exactly how you comment to make it
better for people to jump in and like be
open source contributors I always
thought about it as much more like and
consumer-facing like I guess processing
in the in so has this netted like
different kinds of projects yeah I think
so I mean at the the user base is so
much broader and we really try to
highlight that so that's the other piece
of it is like actively doing events or
curating homepage sketches or galleries
or doing outreach in like working with
specific groups and being like well what
does it mean you know in your context
what what are the useful examples or
like do maybe we need to translate this
also Spanish and then what are the
relevant like examples or concepts
they're doing these just like change the
metaphors we're using to teach instead
of like assuming that you use the same
object that we're talking about so yeah
the projects are just they reflect you
know a wider range of people and like
different ideas and are they like
chiefly art projects or or what mainly
but I think it's being used in a lot of
other contexts too like visualization
stuff I see it like in news and like
blog post kind of things as a showing
data or making some point yeah it's I
think wider than just art okay sure so
one thing that I did want to talk to you
about was the Facebook mood manipulator
are you still actively working on that
is that existing in the world still um I
it exists I don't think it works so well
Facebook kind of changes their
underlying infrastructure very regularly
so that does explain how it worked in
the past yeah so it actually I made it
in response to this news in like 2014 or
something like that where it was like
Oh Facebook is like did this study about
move manipulation where they were
showing people either positive or more
negative content and then showing that
this would cause a person themselves to
make more positive or negative posts
with the conclusion that they can
actually influence your mood based on
what they show you in your feed and the
outcry was all about the procedure and
like you didn't get proper permission
like I can't believe Facebook is
experimenting on us I was like a whole
different conversation but I was more
interested in like this question of like
leaves but they can like control our
moods like I don't have time to be mad
about them experimenting right now like
what about this issue
um so things like mood manipulator was
this a Facebook ad on you could get that
basically would give you this interface
that you could it had a few metrics like
positive negative but also like
optimistic pessimistic I think or open
or private something like that I forget
exactly another and then how it is
actually interactive yeah and so you get
to select how much of these things you
want to feel in a given day when you
wake up and then it filters your posts
accordingly so it was it was using a
method called linguistic inquiry word
count or a Luke Li WC that was actually
the same method that the Facebook mood
manipulation study used and it's it's
pretty like straightforward it's
basically just looking at the words in a
post and trying to tag them at with
different qualifiers you know this is a
positive word or this is the pronoun and
then all of these different you know and
results like openness or hopefulness are
based on what percentage of the words
are in this category of that category so
you just like added up like an equation
have you thought about doing a version
to like post 2016 election yeah the
other side of Facebook yeah I actually
think they I've seen some things like
that like to see other echo-chamber
I wonder
I wonder what it would be what would be
the appropriate add-on now because I
think now people are so used to that
idea like of course there are many doing
my mood of course yeah you know they're
filtering out certain things or
targeting me it also seems difficult
given like how much like app and like
mobile browser traffic they have right
now I guess I mean I don't know how much
it's changed since 2014 but I imagine
it's gonna which is super difficult and
so what have you done many other
extensions you so one that comes to mind
is this extension for Google Hangouts
yes I made with kind of McDonald's it
was called us Plus which is kind of a
play on Google+ and the idea is that you
install it in your hangout and it would
measure what it would do speech to text
and like measure the words that you're
saying and analyze them and then it
would also analyze your facial
expression and it would try to kind of
optimize your conversation and then give
like feedback individually so like I
might be it might notice that I'm like
being much more negative or pessimistic
than my conversation partner and so it
showed me an image like stop being such
a downer or something like that or my
favorite feature was if you are talking
a lot more than the other person it
would just Auto mute you know you've
been on a muted for talking too much
until there was more of a balance you
can be it so surprising that you like
you're the one building these tools when
you seem to have like a very high EQ for
other people maybe you don't feel that
way though ah yeah I'm not sure what the
answer is I feel like I am very
sensitive to other people but then I
just like my output I'm always feel like
lost like I'm like okay this person like
I'm supposed to say something reassuring
or like you know make the situation
comfortable right now like but what and
what do I say I think more people have
that feeling than you think yeah because
there was it also that like box project
you guys made right what was that one
called like the it would tell someone
what to do on their date like at a
certain point in time or the converse EQ
yeah these ones oh yeah is that what you
thing about I didn't yeah it was green
yeah yeah
the special version we made for our
wedding so their silver to match the
color theme yeah this was a project I
did a a while ago it's called person
Cuban it's just like a centerpiece for
conversation and it would kind of sit in
the middle of your table and detect like
who was talking and then try to give you
to single one or two word cues of what
to do or actually what to say or talk
about was it parsing the conversation or
was it just like throwing random stuff
out um yeah it was it was listening the
conversation and I can't go into the
specifics of that one I mean a lot of
these projects are sort of working with
people kind of desire to buy into things
and not in a superficial light like you
give someone a product in you tell them
it does something and they really start
to they kind of want to believe it or
they they so like with the us plus
project I was talking to this reporter
and we were doing an interview over us
Plus and she was you know towards the
end and she's kind of like well do you
know this is great but like is this
really working if you feel sort of
random like how how smart is this thing
and I was about to explain how like yeah
you know speech-to-text is not that
great and an analysis we're using is
actually just be for longer bits of task
whatever but at that moment is like it's
like stop being so doubtful or something
and she was like oh my god I know very
radical right now thank you that's like
we remember these moments where it works
for us and we forget more the times
already just doesn't work are the the
physical objects more effective or less
effective than they like to plug into
the website sir I think they're more
effective in the sense that like it's
amazing what a physical object can do to
just get people like an excuse and so
that was part of the thinking of the
conversa cube because it was like you
know people are really just starting to
get smartphones or I've heard to be more
widespread and I was like what about
this thing that we're all carrying these
objects around like that's that's
interesting what is that
so yeah I think having an object people
are instantly like ready to just sort of
act differently or like put aside some
of their normal patterns and see what
this thing does in the space um the apps
and extensions are nice though because
it means I don't have to like get
objects to people is like anyone can
download in the reach is so much wider
and what I really like about it is this
question of like okay so you saw the
little video trailer and you have maybe
you feel upset or excited or confused
but like then you could just click
download and do you and if you do then
like II how do you use this app and why
and like you really have a choice it's
not just something you see in like news
about it's like a real choice in front
of you hmm
because I was wondering like how often
you get pulled towards a commercial
interest with these projects because I
think like we were talking before we
start started recording about people
asking you to like make a startup or or
misunderstanding the project as a
startup do you ever feel like I mean the
cube is a perfect example like the
desire to do like a giant Kickstarter
for something like that yeah sometimes I
did this I also had this like happiness
hat that would detect if you're smiling
and then like to dab you on the back of
the head until you started the smiling
again to train your brain and that one
like people were really like writing me
asking to buy them I test for me it's
it's just like how I know how much since
I've seen friends you Kickstarter's I
know how much time goes into just like
figuring out manufacturing and
production and everything and that's not
where I want to spend my time
particularly so I think like the
software gets to that point of mass
distribution so yeah so one thing that I
am curious about is like how people do
consume and even buy digital art or
digital media in general I know that
like you you make you know websites and
apps and stuff and not everything's
physical so it's like kind of hard to
sell but where do you see that going as
far as like people consuming and
purchasing it yeah it's interesting
because I don't think anyone has found
the ideal model yet I know a few artists
that have found something that works for
them like they have a specific contract
they use for selling a website or
transferring ownership of something but
there's not like one universal way of
dealing with it in the way that there is
with like you know selling up painting
or something like that or selling a
sculpture and there's also the
trickiness of just like if I sell you a
digital file what is there anything
wrong with like just making a copy and
giving it to someone else like is there
some difference between the copy of a
file or the original or if I sell you a
you know an app and the app no longer
works with your current version of your
phone is that still an interesting right
are you like now the project manager for
number image right so people have
different ways around this sometimes
there's contracts for how long you
maintain something but yeah so for me I
don't the only context in which I've
kind of sold an app before
well usually it's freaks I'm just
interesting people trying it and that's
not worry I'm trying to make money but
one time I made a this app that a lot of
people it got to they're like the front
page of Reddit and so that all these
people started downloading it and I
hadn't really built the server for that
you did I was expecting like you know
maybe a thousand people at most and so I
need people to just like stop telling
he's with us so I just like added a
price and then like a few hours later I
felt like oh I feel bad like I just want
to be free but I in that time I made
like a few thousand dollars and oh oh
that's works yeah I'll give refund
everyone do you keep it no I did you
know bought it yeah doing that one
window and I wasn't free like window
yeah that's really grand of like the
exact inversion of almost every other
company yeah it's interesting because I
was wondering about like why there
aren't more digital artists I know
they're like there are obviously a lot
of them but like more prolific more like
really well-known and was wondering is
that like that issue around selling and
buying stuff is actually a part of it
because like you know if you're a
painter if you're the rare combination
of some one
a painter who also has some like
business savvy and can sell stuff like
you can survive where is like someone
like you like you teach at UCLA which is
awesome but like that's not solely your
art right and yeah I'm just curious like
what what like innovative models artists
are trying to like push on right now to
try and create that stuff or if you
think that like maybe everyone becomes
artists and it this is just like the
side thing for lots of people yeah it's
um I think part of the difficulty comes
out of just like the market around
buying selling art is very conservative
because you're agreeing that this
particular object has this value that
you know and it's all kind of consensus
based so there it's very risk adverse in
the first place so anything digital is
like first of all just like new and not
necessarily like we've established this
is art and it's okay and then also like
how do you own it and how do you keep in
there's all those questions but I've
seen like different models you know
there's you know things like electric
objects where you can which is a
platform for people to distribute images
and they've tried like a number of
different subscription or selling models
um I was talking with someone that a
company recently where they are trying
to use the blockchain as a way to like
sign kind of like verify the the
originality of a digital file so you
might make a copy but you would have the
bit marked one or something like that uh
but I haven't seen any model that really
like who has worked or has caught on in
any way so yeah I don't know what the
answer is I think that there is one I
mean the thing is like eight I think it
used to be like oh there's these like
digital artists and you're saying like
they're still not really represented in
like the art world at large but also
like every artist is starting to use
technology now like at seeing these you
know I teach in a program that uses
technology but seeing the grad scenes in
fine art it's like they're all like
making gifts and using computers and
using like 3d software so I think
they're going to have to figure out
something
this is not going back into the box
totally or you have to get really good
at painting so is there like what are
you really excited about right now like
what are you what are you working on I
don't know if excited is the right word
but I've been like really obsessed with
just all this home automation stuff and
thinking about Alexa and products like
that Google home and it's it's so
interesting for me compared to something
like Google glass where people were kind
of there was this huge like rejection of
it when it came out whereas with Alexa I
see like oh my parents have one actually
they got like two more for Christmas
just cuz they liked it so much I like my
grandma's got one or my friend has one
and it's like nobody's having such a
knee-jerk reaction to it and I think
they are selling it really differently
they kind of like don't make it too
smart at first they roll it out it's
like oh it's just like a smart speaker
and they don't talk about like all the
really technical things that could be
done or they are doing already and I
think that is like coming really soon
it's like first we have to get people
used to like the talking speaker and
then it could be like the talk you could
have controlled everything and like
knows every detail about you and
extremes it also the lab whatever but um
so and for me it's just like so
provocative that it's in the home and to
think of like the home is the place for
you our first you first learn how to be
a person and like talk to people you
understand what your culture and your
values are and what you know your
history is and a lot of that shaped by
like your interactions with your
environment in some of you've got this
device or this home system that is
answering your questions or talking to
you in a certain way or shaping your
interactions like how does that change
and like that's a pretty small group of
developers that are designing these
things that's very you know sort of
limited set of experiences reviews how
do you account for like the huge range
of people that might be using this so
that's that's what we've been thinking
about and then the project I'm working
on is I'm trying to become
I like Amazon Alexa so but I'm making a
service it's called Lauren and to the
ideas that I will come into your home
and set up all these devices and cameras
and then I'll watch you and you know
control your home for you and try to be
like better than Alexis you know try to
anticipate your needs got a care more
try to you know imagine what what would
this relationship with your home smart
home be like if it was like really
taking two it's full of potential Wow
so now like you're exactly on the
opposite end of the dating yeah I guess
so then this is you're asking earlier
about um whether I ever control people
so I guess I'm a brain the controlling
ends I guess in this case your exam yeah
I know I feel like all your projects
have like basically trained people to
deal with computers as like empathetic
things because they think at least that
there's someone behind it operating it
and now you're like we've reached an AI
and now you're leapfrogging it again to
it become the human behind it yeah yeah
yeah well so another piece of this is
thinking about these services like
TaskRabbit or uber or like where or
Mechanical Turk where you've got some
human on some side of it and you
depending on the service is a different
amount of like humaneness to this person
that's working for you like Amazon
Mechanical Turk like they're just like
an ID number basically and I've seen
these like really interesting ads
interesting but ads for like TaskRabbit
where it's like lifestyle photography
like woman in our home drinking cup of
tea and it's like like life post chores
TaskRabbit
oh wait but like the chores are still
happening like it's just like there's a
person that you don't see that doing
them and then this won't wait okay not
like we eliminated them with technology
so it's kind of you know that's another
angle in this project just like what is
the human behind the scenes and like I
don't know are they enjoying this is
this
are you completely at the service of the
other person that
tries to imagine you're not there or or
is it actually like this relationship in
this case we're like I might have some
connection with them or is there any
place for a human to still be better
than artificial intelligence or it's
like you know Alexa can be able to do
this really soon and I'm actually not as
good well I think that that's the bet
right like the low-level tasks or the
repetitive tasks get automated out and
hopefully like creative like high level
knowledge work tasks are remaining but I
have no idea yeah I mean I think the
things that that's how we like we like
to think that like the things I get
automated are the easy things and the
things that don't are the ones that
require more education and their
training or higher level skills but
actually I think it's it divides more
like the more human sort of emotional
labor is the stuff that just can't get
automate it doesn't have to be high-end
it could just be like person that greet
you at the door like it's harder to
replace that with a robot than driving a
car which is a more complicated skill so
when you have all the cameras set up
around someone's house and you're like
observing them that do you ever feel
that like you're going to just develop
this incredible amount of empathy and
become really attached to them and then
have difficulty when they like turn
austell the Lauren device yeah then I'm
just out um yeah I do kind of wonder i I
think actually what I'm trying to do
with all these projects is just I
realized like bootstrap myself into a
place where I get to have this like
connection with someone and part of that
is because I just feel so bad at doing
that like over like you know I'm with my
friend of the coffee shop he just
strikes up a conversation with the woman
behind the counter and I'm like I don't
know how to do that but I'm going to
build this like huge elaborate system
and then maybe through that while I'm
watching the brush their teeth and like
helping them we'll have some you know
human moment together yeah so yeah maybe
a little bit of that I the plan is that
if you sign up for the service there's
sort of a consultation and we talk for a
moment and beforehand in just so it's
not like totally random personally don't
really know me well but they have
sense of who this person is and we kind
of talk about like what would you or you
know what do you want Lord to do for you
well and then try to enact some of that
through when it actually happens okay
and so the deal is that your physical
body is not going to like enter the
house like you're never going to do like
a chore for them it none of that but
like you can engage like an API with
other services
yes I'm building the system where like
I'll be able to turn on it and off any
electronic device I can like see you at
the door unlock it or not depending like
turn on their shower or not or turn it
off and they can also talk to me like
you know learning what's the weather
today and I ruined but I had this like
high powers argument clock well so I
think it will be ideally it would be
like a year or something fun well I
think it will be like three days or
something because what happens with a
lot of these performances is that people
kind of sign up and they don't know what
to expect and then it usually it's very
interesting and kind of intense but I
don't want to be like too much that you
know it's like you want to go to a movie
and have some different experience but
you want to be like so much that you can
barely deal with it
so I'll limit it to it like some shorter
number of days where like they get a
taste of this feeling okay and then
you're like on the clock for like a few
hours or something well for the whole
time during that like three days or so
but like I can sleep when they're
sleeping and I'll build a system that
tells me like weeks when they're like
yeah so what about that um because that
was wasn't at the electric objects
project where you were like on people's
Facebook pages so yeah well explain that
one so the idea there a little bit
convoluted but they so electric objects
made this they had this idea like anyone
should be able to support art and so
they made this Kickstarter that was like
five dollars and you basically you're
fry dogs goes to commission for artists
to make a piece of art and the only
requirement for the artist was that they
had to incorporate the people that had
supported them in some way and so what I
until you could ask them for a question
or give me your photograph or whatever
so I asked them for all their social
media handles that they wanted to give
and
then for all their like a thousand
backers total I spent five minutes
looking through all their social media
and so I set up this is smart just like
queue them up and like show me open all
their tabs and I would start scrolling
and so this would you could see that
watch online you could go and see
exactly what I was looking at and then
also in the corner of a little box that
was like a camera on me
of me like you know reacting to their
stuff yeah is like a social chair thing
yet yeah so it lasted for a week I did
like eight hours a day or something and
then it got through all when Dossett
people just like and did you give them
any feedback or was such as you as
observer um I liked things sometimes I
didn't want to get like I only had five
minutes so I didn't like comment or
anything like that but yeah it was
mostly just me observing but it was also
real time and I was going alphabetically
so you could kind there were actually a
couple people that happen to watch while
I was like browsing them no it's kind of
cool cuz I just wonder like if in a
similar vein you start creeping people
out like knowing that they're being
watched by you yeah I think there will
be a weird part of it um and then the
question is like well does this feel
more invasive than like you know google
Dropcam or less or if you know that like
it's a human but like your your camera's
not going anywhere you know I'm the only
one that will see it versus it going
into some archived somewhere potentially
are you going to like log like
advertising terms and try and sell them
stuff that's a good idea I hadn't
thought about that
you know what you need right now I think
alike blared oh yeah exactly do you want
me to order you some of that okay so I
actually heard about you like three or
four or five years ago when I was
running this thing called comedy hack
day which is basically just building
apps that were funny and then demoing
them on stage shows just a hackathon
with like funny projects and I came
across all your stuff all the time
because people just send it to me
and what I always wondered before I met
you with like how in on the joke you
were like if you're this girl knows is
funny I laughing yeah like if you're
just this person he's like giving a talk
about her project and like you keep
getting like applause breaks in you
ain't fertilizing I'm just trying to
like learn how to interact with people
and then everyone laughs and then you
think keep presenting yeah until like
meeting you now I like get the sense
that you're very in on the joke but like
how much of your intention is to make
this thing that's actually functional
that helps you interact with people and
how much of it is just to be like point
at something be like this is interesting
maybe it's funny as well mm-hmm um well
first I just love that you didn't hear
like it's this this is people have any
idea was laughing at her um yeah so it's
definitely I give this question a lot
and or sometimes it's asked like you
know are you optimistic or critical
about the future and I'm like yes well
um and then they say which and like well
whichever what the opposite of whatever
using but no two more seriously like I
feel like it's impossible to say you
know this any one thing is like a bad or
good or the right track of the wrong
direction yet we are asked to respond to
things so quickly it's like you scroll
through it and you're supposed to be
like I like that alright I'm going to
write an angry tweet about that thing um
and so I really want to just like make a
space where people can just like
consider things for a moment and sort of
imagine what it is we're getting
ourselves into and so I find humor like
a way to do that because you know you
laugh and then you kind of there's
always some truth to every joke into
people it's it's less like let me
lecture you about this thing we should
all think about and more like here's
something ridiculous now let me tell you
that's the future yeah I mean it's like
I used to work at the onion
like with the term look like Flintstone
vitamin so like kind of a sweet thing
but it has some amount of nutrients I
like that it's like basically your
projects - right yeah I uh and I wonder
like on the flip side like why so much
of this like near-future science fiction
black mirror type TV content is like
almost across the board negative and
like fearful where is like your stuff
which I more often than not like catches
some attention online when you release
it and it's like funny and there don't
seem to be as many like really negative
like the world is ending artists but
like yet the media is like the exact
opposite of that give any idea why those
like shows are successful I think they
tap into a fear that people have and yet
they present in the way that is sort of
like relatable and not just like you
know doom gloom headline but I think for
me it's like important I guess that's
part of it like yes we feel scared we
feel uncertain things are changing
quickly we don't know what's going to
happen something seemed definitely going
in a terrifying direction um but we
can't just like unwind or rewind and we
can't just stop it from coming so how do
we move forward and so for me it's like
essential to find the parts that are
worth keeping that we are excited about
and try to like do more of that and so I
guess with all these projects it's
always like this layering of both of
those things it's like yes there's this
fear there's the that is totally messed
up like what's going on but then there's
also the part where you're like oh
that's kind of nice you know I just
followed this person around all day
while their phone was like broadcasting
my location and like we had like a
really sweet time I was weird and great
cool like have you ever use like WeChat
where you can just like shake the phone
okay yeah yeah it's like very pointless
but kind of sweet yeah yeah have you um
have you like dug into your projects and
tried to like retain people in your apps
for longer periods of time to like
create a lasting effect or a more
lasting effect that's such a good
question
I guess not I guess I mean there are a
lot of like friendships that have sort
of come out of these projects and then
I'll continue to you know then you know
watch a webcam in their bedroom right
not the less of that I mean I actually
met my husband through one of these
projects which is I when I was doing the
social Turkish things he was actually
happened to be one of the people
watching and giving advice unlike the
last date and then like Road to knee
after victims like wow this product or
so interested like I would love to meet
up and then we um yeah so crazy yeah
yeah yeah right so if you always ask
that project successful and I like well
I mean yeah kind of I got a husband out
of it I guess but I would yeah obviously
but normally someone who has like
helping you interact and being more and
and what's his attitude toward other
people like like obviously or maybe not
obviously he likes to be on the computer
side of your projects or does he like to
be told what to do oh um he needs no
instruction he's just like totally
comfortable okay yeah he's got little
computers he's comfortable people yeah I
just keep him around if I like he's
jealous yeah trying to learn and so and
so what is he he's a digital artist as
well right yeah what kind of stuff does
he work on well so we work on a lot of
projects together so we did this us+
project that I mentioned his he's maybe
a little bit dives deeper and some of
the theory and technical things that are
possible and so right now he's working a
lot of like machine learning experiment
and doing some really close up of that
recent before that he was really focused
on computer vision so he did this one
project where he had this like pile of
mirror balls like disco balls and then
he was had a number of projectors that
were aimed at them and a number of
cameras and the camera would like detect
for every single surface of every single
ball was and then
project the proper pattern so that when
it bounced off of the falls it would
create these patterns on the walls
luckily morphing like you know
arrangements that we're all like super
calculated based on all these angles and
reflection yeah that's pretty technical
yeah yeah very cool though man and so
okay so if someone like likes your work
like in what's-his-name just people know
Kyle McDonald's yeah it's a someone like
your work or Kyle's work and they want
to start doing this kind of thing where
would you like where do they get start
do they go to art school do they learn
like processing what do they do yeah um
I mean I think tool like processing or
p5.js openFrameworks Arduino for
electronics these are really great
places to just start messing around
school is great but I don't think it's
like necessary at all I think what's
really actually exciting about these
tools is that there are these
communities of people online and like
you know artists have always been good
at making community but I think
especially digital artists like that is
where they go to find each other and so
I would say just start experimenting
hang online try to figure out like what
I guess the biggest thing is like what
is your unique way of looking at the
stuff or working with it you know a lot
of easy to make something sparkly but
like what what do you have to say or
what do you see in it that's different
than what others do do you find that by
like contemplating or do you find it by
just doing stuff I think it's different
for everyone I just start with like my
anxieties and force of nature
oh yeah I guess is free of it but yeah I
think doing stuff is usually a good
place to go if you having it's not
coming in your thoughts and womb like I
guess wrapping up like water um for
people in art school like what is your
advice to them like how could someone
make it most out of it hmm I think so a
couple things um you know and the thing
you'll probably hear from your teachers
are like this is your moment to take
risks and to fail and you should do that
and um
you know that's pretty easy but um the
people are the thing that is really
special about grad school you know
you're the network that you make with
the teachers or the people on the
community in the alumni but especially
like your peers in the program these are
the people that he'll continue to run
into and connect with through your life
and so just to take you know not to be
so focused on your work that you don't
connect with the people around you and
then the thing I wish I'd known I was
like to ask questions like I always felt
like I was supposed to know what to do
and I never had any clue and so I just
tried to like get through it out getting
trouble or something but now I have
always seems I just like asking me
questions all day long or like I like
why I wish I had done that like I could
have gotten so much value out of it was
like I didn't know you could ask
anything incredibly helpful I'm like
when I was just starting to like do some
Python stuff like having that mentor
that I could ask really dumb questions
to made all the difference when it came
to just like I would learn things that I
wasn't even intending to learn because
they're just like oh you just do that
and then it works
you're gonna go god I wish and in the my
last question for you is uh just like
influences so artists I guess most
obvious but done like any kind of like
books or film or anything like that I
would say artists you know
ones that are sort of further than the
careers that I'm looking at her like
Sophie Kyle jilma gede both of them kind
of dealing with surveillance and
watching in really personal ways a lot
of like performance artists like
touching Shea who like tied himself with
a rope to his collaborator for a year
and they didn't separate and I just
think of this as like you know we do
know it's like interaction design but
like you know a rope can like change
your life I don't think they spoke to
each other after that project ended Wow
and yeah and then I guess in terms of
movies
Oh actually enjoy I read a lot of books
and I read a lot of fiction
my favorite is like Joyce Carol Oates
and because I heard that like fiction
changes your personality to change I
agree that however I can be better than
you people I'm not actually a joy skill
it's like the one that you want it's
usually your character really twisted
and I also love this movie called
Synecdoche New York where it's like this
artist kind of building this world that
he sort of loses students often but the
last scene is like him listening to this
Oh the spoiler alert of this audio tape
where he's got these headphones and it's
like instructing what to do and it's
like go up the stairs into this like set
of a house East world he's build and if
I go up the stairs lie down in bed close
your eyes now like die something like
that I think that was like the end of
his life yeah so that's my dream for end
of life Wow
character we were definitely going to
get there probably there right now yeah
right an audio book cool right so if
someone wants to like learn more about
you follow you online where do you like
publish stuff yeah um so website Lauren
- McCarthy yes that's wrong um and yeah
you can go there or you can um and
that's where I publish most things like
most of my pieces are first kind of
released online as videos or
intervention so you might not even know
it's my work but you might see something
pop up that are is outraging people in
your social media feed or something like
that there you go that's you will you be
doing anything this summer that people
can like check out yeah so I'm doing
this home project
um and I'm actually going to be open
soon for signups um so you can look out
for that and potentially we can uh I can
come watch you in your home and you can
share everything
and that'll be on your like your website
your Twitter call service
yeah and then the I guess the other
thing to check out is like p5.js org
which is this platform that I lead the
development of if you're interested in
you know making some code art yourself
to okay thank you yeah thank you so
you're good
you